Russian drones have attacked the city of
komolnitzki in Western Ukraine damaging
hundreds of houses according to the
mayor a video circulated on Russian
social media shows CCTV footage of the
blast in the early hours of Saturday
reports suggest several drones destroyed
a major munition zeppo Natasha Butler
has more from Levy
well they've been a series of Russian
missile attacks in the past 24 hours in
Western Ukraine most significantly in
the town of terminal pill now that is
the town where Ukraine's Eurovision song
contest contestants come from the attack
happened just before that singing
competition began in the British city of
Liverpool according to local authorities
there two people were injured an attack
also a few hours before in the city of
Kamel nitsky now that is just e east of
here in leviv a huge Fireball was seen
rising over the city it is reported that
an ammunitions Depot was hit no
confirmation though or for on that from
Ukrainian authorities now all this comes
as Ukraine's President Vladimir
zielinski is in Berlin meeting the
German Chancellor Olaf Schultz Germany
has just announced its biggest military
aid package yet worth some 3 billion US
dollars